حصل المنتخب السعودي على ركله جزاء امام
المكسيك بالدقيقه الاخيره والنتيجه 1 - 1
2 1 للسعوديه تاهل دور 16 مع السلامه مين
اللاعب السعودي اللي لازم يسدد الركله
ببساطه محمد كنو انا اقول لك السبب ليش
لانه محمد كانه من ابرز وجوب البطوله كل
الحسابات العالميه تتغنى باللاعب هذا
اللاعب هذا مو هيبان موهبه توقع ان الحمد
لله يعني بداياتها الان سالم يعني ما شاء
الله تبارك الله برضه يعني لكن اتكلم عن
محمد كانو والله همم سالم الدوسري لازم هو
سالم الدوسري امس ضيعه صراحه وهو ما يضيع
لكن انا اشوف امس كان الحظ مع المنتخب
السعودي يعني ما ساعدهم الحرب مين اللاعب
السعودي اللي لازم يسدد همم بالنهايه هي
ضربه حظ
ممكن تتسجل ممكن ما تتسجل
يا سالم يوم كان شات البلنتي
تاخر في القرار قرار متاخر انا بفضل سلمان
الفرج الثقه عنده عاليه بدون مناقشه انا
افضل سالم هو اللي يكون هداف ضربه يعني
احنا عندنا في الحجاز في السعوديه هناك في
لفظه دارجه نقول عن اللاعب اللي يتمكن من
المباراه يركب المباراه محمد كانه ما شاء
الله تبارك الله قدام الارجنتين
بالمباراه صعبه
نواف العبد والرشحه سالم لا سالم قرارات
ومتاخره
يعني عنده ثبات انفعالي كانه جدا كل شيء
تتكلم عن المهاره تتكلم عن التكتيك تتكلم
عن المزاج تتكلم عن تبادل الافعال تتكلم
عن التعامل مع المتجر والمجرات الكبرى
محمد كنو جوهرتنا العالم قاعد يتفرج
عالاها ويستمتع فيها شكرا جزيلا